[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد هذه الليله معكم السيئه
بعاصي في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى هذه الصوره الان في جنوب
الخرطوم حيث تشتعل ان يران لليوم الثاني
على التوالي في مستودعات الوقود والغاز
الرئيسيه جراء المعارك في محيطها
وهذا هو المشهد في كندا ونيران اخرى لكن
بفعل الطبيعه حيث وصفت حرائق الغابات في
جنوب البلاد بالاكبر في تاريخها
وفي الولايات المتحده وتحديدا نيويورك
ضباب يلف المدينه بسبب الحرائق المندلعه
في مناطق بكندا فتسبب في الغاء مئات
الرحلات رحلات الطيران واطلاق تحذيرات
للسكان من عواقب التلوث
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
النيران تشتعل في جنوب العاصمه السودانيه
لليوم الثاني بعد وصول معارك السيطره على
مجمع اليرموك العسكري الى مستودعات الوقود
الرئيسيه وفي غرب دارفور السلطات تعلن
الولايه منطقه منكوبه بعد سقوط اكثر من
800 قتيل في الاشتباكات المتواصله منذ
اسابيع وزير الخارجيه السعودي يتحدث عن
بوادر ايجابيه للتواصل لهدنه جديده مع
اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
واستطضارب المعطيات بشان هجوم كييف المضاد
موسكو تعلن صدى توغل اوكراني وصفته
بالمفاجئ وواسع النطاق في زبوروجيا الجيش
الاوكراني ينفي بدء هجومه ويؤكد ان القوات
الروسيه تراجعت نحو 15 كيلومترا جراء
تدبير السد كخوفكا
داخل روسيا الجزيره تستطلع حركه نزوح مع
تصاعد القصف على المقاطعه
تحركات عسكريه تفاقم التوتر في شرق اسيا
طوكيو تتهم الصين بالدفع بقطعتين حربيتين
في مياه اليابان الاقليميه وبعد مخاوف
معلنه من الجوار بيجين تشدد على ان
مناورتها الجويه مع روسيا لا تستهدف اي
دوله وبايضا يؤكد في محادثاتهم مع السونات
على اهميه التحالف الامني مع بريطانيا
واستراليا لتعزيز الامن في شرق اسيا
حرائق غابات تستعر في جنوب كندا ودخانها
يخنق ولايات الساحل الشرقي الامريكي
النيران تجبر الاف الكنديين على النزوح
وتلتهم مئات الالاف من الهكتارات تريدو
يصفها بالاسوا على الاطلاق ويعزوها للتغير
المناخي والسلطات في الولايات المتحده
تحذر ملايين السكان من ارتفاع منسوب
التلوث
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا الجدل بشان الهجوم
الاوكراني المضاد الذي يعود للواجهه بعد
ترجيحات بانه بدا بالفعل لاستطلاع ارائكم
بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي ما هي افاق ومالات اي هجوم
مضاد قد تقوم به اوكرانيا وقد جاءت
النتيجه على النحو التالي نحو
23% صوت لصالح القول ان اي ان افاق اي
هجوم مضاد سيكون تحولا لصالح كييف في حين
صوت نحو 46% بالقول انها دعايه بلا تاثير
اخيرا قال نحو 31% ان المالات هي انكسار
يكرس الوجود الروسي هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهري
على الشاشه لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه
يتجدد يوميا ونظت الرقو خلاله لقضايا
مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وفي الحصاد ايضا احاول وزيره الخارجيه
الفرنسيه كاترين كولونا التي حدثتنا عن
رؤيه باريس ومقاربتها للملفات الاقليميه
لا سيما التقارب العربي مع ايران والازمه
السياسيه في لبنان
[موسيقى]
ونبدا مباشره من السودان حيث يستمر اشتعال
النيران في مستودع للنفط والغاز عقب هجوم
امس على مجمع اليرموك لصناعات الدفاعيه
جنوبيه الخرطوم
ينضم الينا من ام درمان مدير مكتب الجزيره
المسلم الكباشي المسلم نقترب معك اكثر من
المشهد
نعم يلسي المشهد هو استمرار المعارك بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في كل مواقع
العاصمه المثلثه في مدن العاصمه المثلث
الثلاث اليوم هنالك ضربات وغارات جويه على
منطقه شرق النيل ولكن اكثر المعارك ضراوه
منذ اكثر من يومين كانت حول منطقه اليرموك
منطقه مصنع اليرموك للاسلحه والذخائر الذي
يقع في جنوبي الخرطوم العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم وهذا هذه المنطقه كانت محل صراع
ومحل اشتباكات منذ يومين اشتباكات شريطه
الضراوه يحاول تحاول قوات الدعم السريحي
اقتحام
منطقه اليرموك وخاصه منطقه المصانع ثم ترد
هذه الجيش شرد هذه القوات وتعود القوات من
جديد ولا تزال المعركه دائره هنالك دون ان
تصل الى نهايتها ومن الواضح ان القوات الد
سريع ارادت ان تستهدف هذه المنطقه
الاستراتيجيه لرمزيتها اكثر من
اهميتها في المعارك رمزيتها لكونها مصانع
الاسلحه ولكونها
مستودعات الذخائر للجيش السوداني وبالتالي
اما انهم ارادوا تحييدها من هذه من هذه
الاشتباكات والهجومات او ارادوا ان
يتخذوها موقعا اذا جاءت مفاوضات او من
خلالها مفاوضات التي تجري في في الدوحه
انهم
يستولون على منطقه ذاتي عمق وبعد ووزن
استراتيجي يمكن ان يقدم لهم اوراق تفاوض
افضل مما هم عليه الان ولكن على كل حال
المعارك في كل الخرطوم تدور منذ ان
توقفت اخر الهدنان منذ حوالي اربعه او
خمسه ايام لا تزال المعارك تدور وخاصه ان
الجيش يقول لا سبيل الى التوقف عن هذه
المعارك ان لم تتم الاستجابه لش متطلبات
الاتفاق اتفاق جده سواء اعلان المبادئ او
الاتفاق الذي بموجبه تمت خدمتان تمت
هدنتان حتى الان ورفعت هاتين الخدنتان اما
الجزء الثاني من المعارك طبعا مركز الصراع
في هذه المعرفه منذ بداتها هو ولايه
الخرطوم ولكن ايضا المركز الثاني هو
دارفور وخاصه وغرب دارفور في الجنان عاصمه
غرب دارفور التي انقطعت عن العالم وانقطع
عنها العالم
بسبب
بسبب تدهور والتوقف ومرافق الخدمه مرافق
الاتصالات مرافق المياه مرافق
الدواء والمستشفيات الان مدينه معزوله عن
العالم لا ندري عنها شيئا على كل ان اشكرك
من ام درمان مدير مكتب الجزيره المسالمه
الكباشي ونتابع كل هذه التفاصيل التي
تحدثت عنها في التقرير التالي
في دائره العاصمه السودانيه تتركز معارك
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع مع
اقتراب المعارك من انهاء شهرها الثاني
لا تزال اعمده الدخان تتصاعد في العاصمه
لم يغب الطيران الحربي عن السماء ولم يصمت
دوري الانفجارات وسط وغربي الخرطوم
وجنوبيه ام درمان احد اهم مراكز القتال
خلال الساعات الماضيه مجمع اليرموك
للصناعات الدفاعيه جنوبيه الخرطوم تعرض
للمصنع عام 2012 لهجوم المدمر واشار اصابع
الاتهام الى اسرائيل حينها تقول قوات
الدعم السريع اليوم انها سيطرت على المصنع
الاستراتيجي للجيش ينشر دعم مقاطع فيديو
يقول انها لقواته في المجمع الصناعي يرد
الجيش بالتاكيد على ان المنطقه تتعرضت
لهجوم الى الدعم السريع لكن الجيش تصدى
لها وكبدها خسائر قبل فرارها بحسب تعبير
الجيش بجوار مصنع اليرموك ثمه مجمع خزانات
للوقود يغذي المنطقه كلها اشتعلت فيه
النيران وتصاعدت اعمده الدخان على مدى
ساعات خلت هكذا يبدو المشهد في الخرطوم
قتال يدور الان للسيطره على الاسلحه
وخزانات الوقود في العاصمه
اذا عند دائره الخرطوم لا تبدو الامور
هادئه نحو اقصى الغرب تتجه اعين
السودانيين القلقين على مستقبل البلاد على
بعد اقل من 15 كيلو مترا عن الحدود مع
تشاد المجاوره تفيد التقارير بان اكثر من
850 شخصا قتلوا واصيب اكثر من 2000 يقول
حاكم ولايه غرب دارفور ان مدينه الجنينه
بل الولايه كلها اصبحت منكوبه ومعزوله عن
العالم مع استمرار القتال معارك متواصله
لاسابيع يزيد من ضراوتها تداخل الاطراف
المتناحره الدعم السريع والجيش والقبائل
المسلحه في المنطقه نقابه الاطباء تصف
الاسوا وتقول ان الميليشيات دمرت كل
الموارد ونهبت الاسواق وجففت موارد المياه
مع انقطاع لشبكه الاتصالات الاصعب من كل
هذا ان الناجين حتى الان محرومون من فرصه
الخروج الامن من المنطقه المعزوله كليه في
ظل كل هذا المشهد القاتمي من هناك يقول
الجيش السوداني ان الميليشيا وصفه تعمل
على توسيع دائره الحرب حرب لا يبدو انها
ستنتهي في المدى المنظور رغم التحركات
السياسيه في الاقليم الاهم بالنسبه
لملايين السودانيين ان تنتهي الحرب قبل ان
تسوء الامور اكثر مما هي عليه الان
في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان هناك
بوادر ايجابيه في المحادثات بشان التطورات
في السودان ودعا الوزير السعودي الاطراف
في السودان للالتزام بالاتفاق ووقف اطلاق
النار
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزم
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص عمل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان
ينضم الينا في الاستوديو الدكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم الكاتب والمحلل السياسي السوداني
مرحبا بك دكتور ماذا تعني السيطره
المحتمله على مجمع اليرموك
يسيطر رمزيه اكثر من كونها ذات اهميه
عسكريه على اعتبار ان هذا المصنع خرج عن
نطاق الخدمه منذ بدايه الحرب وقامت قوات
الجيش السوداني بنقل معظم الذخائر
والاسلحه الموجوده فيه الى مقر قياده
المدرعات هو مجمع عسكري صناعي ضخم قوات
الدعم السريع دخلت من الناحيه الشماليه
للمجمع
واتخذت منه بوابه للدعايه لتحقيق نصر
معلوم ان القوات الدعم السريع في خلال
بدايه الحرب استهدفت الوحدات العسكريه
الرئيسيه في العاصمه قياده العامه سلاح
المدرعات سلاح المهندسين قاعده وادي سيدنا
الجويه وعندما صارت هذه الاهداف عصيه
عليها اتجهت الى اهداف اخرى وغير
التكتيكها واصبحت تهاجم وحدات عسكريه فنيه
اكثر من كونها قتاليه مثل سلاح الكيمياء
قياده الدفاع الجوي في العمارات
التصنيع الحربي واخيرا المصنع اليرموك
في موضوع مصنع اليرموك ما رمزيه
اي سيطره عليها لانك قلت ان المعركه رمزيه
يعني مره رمزيه هنا هذا واحد من المجمعات
الصناعيه الكبيره هذا هو المصنع الذي يمد
القوات المسلحه السودانيه بالذخائر
وبالتالي لو اهميه رمزيه هي الان هو موقع
مهم فوق ذلك فان اهميته تكتسب ايضا من
قربه من سلاح المدرعات وهو اقوى اسلحه
الجيش السوداني طيب الان وصلنا يعني الان
هناك حديث
من جانب وزير الخارجيه السعوديه قبل قليل
يتحدث عن احتمال تجدد الهدنه مع اليات
مراقبه مشدده اكثر هل تعتقد ان
الظروف اصبحت سانحه لكي نتوقع نتيجه
مختلفه عن السابق
كان من المفترض ان يتم تنفيذ هدنه لمده
يوم واحد اليوم يتم من خلالها تنفيذ بعض
البنود الوارده في اتفاق جده وتم الاتفاق
على تسليم ثلاث مستشفيات في العاصمه وهي
مستشفى الخرطوم مستشفى شرق النيل ومستشفى
القابلات او المشهور باسم مستشفى الدايات
ان يتم تسليمها لوزاره الصحه السودانيه
ولكن المعارك التي دارت امس خلت بهذا
الاتفاق او اعاقه تنفيذه الان هناك حديث
عن تنفيذ هذا الاتفاق
بهدنه تستمر لمده يوم واحد ويفترض ان تتمه
يوم السبت ولكن الناظر الى المشهد الكلي
يجد ان من الصعوبه بمكان ان تسري هدنه في
ظل الظروف الحاليه الوقائع الميدانيه
الحاليه قوات الدعم السريع موجوده في كل
مستشفيات العاصمه تقريبا موجوده في مساكن
المدنيين موجوده في الاجهزه الخدمات
العامه مثل التحكم القومي للكهرباء مراكز
انتاج المياه موجوده في الجامعات موجوده
في المدارس وهي لا تمتلك مقار مركزيه كي
تلجا اليها بعد مبادر الجيش السوداني
بتدمير معظم مقراتها في العاصمه وكلماتها
تقريبا تعرضت للغصب وبالتالي الناظر الى
المشهد الكلي يجد ان انه من الصعوبه بمكان
على قوات الدعم السريع ان تلتزم بما ورد
في اتفاق جده والحديث هنا عن اليات مراقبه
مشدده اكثر كيف يمكن ان يكون يعني مع عساه
ان يكون هذه اشكاليه تواجهها الوساطه لان
كما تعلمين فان معظم البعثات او كل
البعثات الدبلوماسيه في السودان خرجت من
الخرطوم بعضها نقل اعماله الى بورسودان
والبعض الاخر غادر السودان نهائيا
وبالتالي هذه الجهات لا تمتلك اي اليات
لتنفيذ تراقب بها ما اتفق على تنفيذه في
اتفاق الجده بخلاف الهلال الاحمر والصليب
الاحمر وهذه لا تستطيع ان تدخل منازل
المدنيين لا تستطيع ان تتاكد من مغادره
قوات الدعم السريع لكل محطات الخدمه
للجامعات للمدارس منتشره في كل مكان
تقريبا بطريقه دفعت العديد من السودانيين
للحديث عن عن هذه الحرب تحولت من حرب مع
الجيش الى حرب على الشعب السوداني وعلى
المواطنه العادي شكرا جزيلا لك في
الاستديو الدكتور مزمل ابو القاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي السوداني شكرا
الى اوكرانيا حيث يتجدد اللغط بشان هجوم
كييف المضاد بعد ترجيح مسؤولين روس
وغربيين انهم بدا بالفعل وفي هذا السياق
اعلن وزير الدفاع الروسي سرجي شويغو عن
احباط محاوله للقوات الاوكرانيه لاختراق
خطوط دفاعات القوات الروسيه في محور
زابوريا ووصف شويغو الهجوم بالمفاجئين
وغير المسبوق
حاول اللواء الالي الاوكراني 47 الليله
الماضيه اختراق خطوط دفاعات القوات
الروسيه في محور زابولوجيا بفضل
الاستخبارات تم الكشف في الوقت المناسب عن
تحركات العدو وتوجيه ضربه استباقيه له
بمساعده المدفعيه والطيران والاسلحه
المضاده للدبابات تم ايقاف العدو في
الاتجاهات الاربعه وخسر 30 دبابه واحدى
عشره عربه مشاه ونحو 350 من قواته خلال
معارك اليوم الماضي خسر العدو اكثر من 900
عسكري وثلاثه وثلاثين دبابه واكثر من 25
عربه مشاه وثلاثه مدفعيات واسلحه اخرى
ونشرت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه مقاطع فيديو
قالت انها تظهر تدمير دبابات واليات
اوكرانيه خلال صد القوات الروسيه للهجوم
الاوكراني في زابوريا وتظهر الصور تعرض
رتلا من الدبابات للقصف
في المقابل نفى الجيش الاوكراني ما ينقلها
الاعلام الغربي عن مصادر من داخل الجيش
نفسه عن بدء هجوم مضاد بينما قالت
المتحدثات باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب
الاوكرانيه نتاليا هوم ان ارتفاع منسوب
المياه وعمليات الاجلاء على الضفه اليسرى
من خرسون اجبرت القوات الروسيه على نقل
مواقعها والتراجع الى مسافات تصل الى نحو
15 كيلومترا
ي منسوب المياه قره القوات الروسيه
للتراجع لمسافات تتراوح بين خمسه الى خمسه
عشر كيلو مترا لكنهم لم يتوقفوا عن القصف
واستهدفوا مناطق غمرتها المياه في الضفه
اليمنى للنهر في خرسون اطلقوا النار على
مركز للتسوق معتبرينه مركزا حيث يمكنهم
جمع المساعده للناس لكن المياه مستمره في
تدفق كما يبقى ولسوء الحظ استهداف العدو
لخرسون بالمدفعيه مستمر
في هذه الاثناء قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
ان اوكرانيا لديها افاق جيده للغايه
لتطوير برنامجها الصاروخي واوضح ريزني كوف
ان تطوير الصواريخ الاوكرانيه يستهدف
زياده مداها الى اكثر من الف كيلو متر
واشار ريزني كوفي لانه تمت الموافقه على
البرنامج الصاروخي وتخصيص ميزانيه رسميه
لزياده المدى وفيما يتعلق بحادث اغراق
طراد موسكووفا الروسي اكد الوزير
الاوكراني ان الطراد الروسي اغرق بصواريخ
نبتون الاوكرانيه
ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز الدويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي مرحبا بك
لواء فايز اتهام لاوكرانيا بانها بدات
الهجوم المضاد واوكرانيا تنفي ولكن ما هي
المؤشرات القاطعه التي يمكن الوقوف عندها
لنعرف ان بدا هذا الهجوم ام لا
اولا هناك عده معايير حجم الهجوم
اتجاهات الهجوم
وطبيعه المقاربه العسكريه
الان ما هو حجم الهجوم الذي تم الحديث عنه
من قبل وزير الدفاع تحدث عن 1500 عنصر وعن
150 عربه ما بين عربه قتال مشاه او عربه
قتال مصفحه بمعنى اخر ان حجم القوه هو اقل
من حجم لواء وقد يكون بحجم مجموعتي قتال
بينما التقارير تشير الى ان حجم القوه
التي تم اعدادها لشن الهجوم ترقى الى تسعه
الوي مدرعه
الامكانات التي قدمت ونشرها مركز دراسات
الحرب تحدث عن 500 دبابه عن حوالي الف
مدفع 900 عربه قتال مدرعه وبالتالي لا
يعقل ان يتم شن الهجوم بهذا الحجم من
القوه قياس مع القوه لتم اعدادها عندما
كنا قبل تفجير السد كنا نتوقع ان يكون
الهجوم من خرسون
الان الحديث عن قاطع معين بحجم قوات معينه
وسمي هذا الهجوم
تحت
مسميين اما عمليات جس النبض او عمليات
الاستطلاع بالقوه في كثير من الحروب
يلجا المهاجم الى اختبار قدره الدفاعات
المقابله من خلال عمليات محدوده بمجموعه
قتال او اقل من لواء وفي بعض الحالات
يحاول ان يجري ما يطلق عليه استطلاع
بالقوه الزج بحجم قتالي جيد
هل بالضروره ان نكون نحن امام مشهد
ينتظر هذا الهجوم المضاد الكبير الذي يعلن
ساعه يعلن وفق ساعه صفر معينه ام ان هذا
الهجوم المضاد يمكن ان يتخذ ربما شكل
عمليات نوعيه تؤدي الى النتيجه التي
تريدها اوكرانيا
الان بعد تفجير السد
اصبح من الملزم من وجهه نظري على القوات
الاوكرانيه
عن اعاده ترتيب اوراقها من حيث
حشد القوه تجميع القوه اعاده تقييم الموقف
الاستراتيجي تحديد الاهداف تحديد اتجاهات
الهجوم لان اتجاه هجوم رئيسي فقدت القدره
على استخدامه لا يمكن لها ان تعيد توضيع
القوه خلال 48 ساعه لهذا السبب انا رايي
التحليل الشخصي الهجوم الرئيسي سواء اتحدث
ام لم يتحدثوا لم يبدا بعد لكن هذه عمليات
تحضيريه من اعاده من اجل اعاده تموضع
القوات الرئيسيه لتتناسب مع الخطه الجديده
هنا العمليه انا اسميها واجزم استطلاع
بالقوه لتحديد نقاط القوه ونقاط الضعف في
الجدار الدفاعي الروسي وبناء عليه
سيتم توضيع القوه الرئيسيه
وتحديد اتجاهات حركتها انطلاقا من حجم
المعلومه التي جمعت هذه الوحدات حتى وان
فشلت هذا على الجانب الاوكراني ولكن ماذا
عن الجانب الروسي كيف برايك استعد لهذا
الهجوم المضاد المحتمل
يعني منذ اشهر حتى يعني في زبروجيا منذ
اشهر في قرصون منذ تقريبا ما يقارب العام
بعد الانسحاب من قرصون بدا القوات الروسيه
باعداد خطوط دفاعيه في منطقه خرسون كان
طول الخط الدفاعي 120 كيلو متر وبثلاثه
خطوط المسافه بين الخط والاخر مع تقريبا
عشرين كيلو متر كذلك قامت ببناء ثلاثه
خطوط دفاعيه في منطقه زبروجيا وخطوط
دفاعيه في منطقه خاركيف الان ماذا استفادت
روسيا من من عمليه السد اصبح لديها وقت
اضافي لاعاده
تقويه المنظومه الدفاعيه سواء من حيث
المنشات الدفاعيه والحواجز والعوائق
والخنادق او من حيث جلب قوات اضافيه تحررت
نتيجه ما جرى من تغريق وعدم قدره الجيش
الاوكراني على المناوره في تلك المنطقه
فالقوات التي كانت مخصصه للعمل على تلك
الواجهه اصبحت الان متحرره ولو بنسبه
كبيره من هذه القوات سيتم نقلها لتعزيز
الدفاعات في زبالوجيا وخاركيف شكرا جزيلا
لك لوقفه الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
ضيفنا من عمان
تاثيرات تفجير سد كخوفكا لا تقتصر على غمر
اراض وغرق قرى وبلدات باكملها بل هناك خطر
تلوث والغام جرفتها مياه الفيضانات وخارج
حدود المنطقه فقد حذر برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي من امتداد تاثيرات هذه الحادثه
الى ملايين الاشخاص حول العالم بسبب ما
تؤمنه محاصيل هذه المنطقه من مواد غذائيه
اساسيه
مع تبادل الاتهامات بشان الطرف المسؤول عن
ما حدث في سدك خوفكا فان الثابته ان مياه
السد تبدلت من مصدر حياه الى خطر كبير قد
يتعدى حدود الجغرافيا الاوكرانيه يفصل نهر
دنيبر بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه خرسون لكن ضرره كان واحدا على
اراضي ضفتيه وكل من يقطن فيها استنادا الى
رئيس الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه خرسون
فان متوسط ارتفاع المياه بلغ اكثر من خمسه
امتار ونصف المتر وغمرت الاف المنازل هكذا
بدا المشهد عبر الاقمار الصناعيه لبلده
اوليشكي قبل الفيضان وبعده
[موسيقى]
هذه الصور لحقول في بلده كرينكي وهي تفسر
ما اشارت اليه وزاره الزراعه الاوكرانيه
باحتمال خساره ملايين الاطنان من المحاصيل
الزراعيه واحتمال تصحر المنطقه جراء
ليس الزرع الموجود فحسب بل حتى ما حصد منه
قبلا فصوامع تخزين الحبوب كان لها نصيب من
الغمر ايضا على هذا يتعدى الخطر حسب تقدير
برنامج الغذاء العالمي الى ابعد من
المنطقه وساكنها اذ يشمل نحو 30045 مليون
شخص حول العالم بسبب غمر الفيضانات للحبوب
المزروعه حديثا كما ان اسعار السوق
العالميه للسلع الغذائيه وفق البرنامج
الاممي وصلت الى اعلى مستوى لها منذ عشره
اعوام
في روسيا ومع استمرار تعرض المناطق
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا للقصف تستمر حركه
نزوح داخلي للمدنيين في مقاطعه بيلبورود
الروسيه وتقول سلطات المقاطعه انه تم
اجلاء نحو 20 الف شخص من منطقه شبكينسكي
واختار بعض سكان المنطقه وخصوصا من
البلدات التي تتعرض للقصف التطوع للمساعده
في عمليه الاجلاء وايصال المؤن للمحتاجين
رغم الظروف الامنيه التي تعيشها مدينته
الحدوديه مع اوكرانيا يتوجه ايليا كل صباح
الى منطقه شبيكنسكيا المغلقه بسبب تعرضها
للقصف مخاطرا بحياته في سبيل المساهمه في
اجلاء السكان يقول ان واقع الحرب دفعه نحو
هذا الخيار تطوعي في وقت اصبحت فيه نيران
الحرب تطال يوميا اراضي روسيا
اغلب سكان المدينه غادروها ونساعد من يرغب
في المغادره الى الوضع الانساني هناك صعب
للغايه ما دفعني للمخاطره تطوعا بعد ان
اجليته عائلته الحرب اصبحت تدور على
اراضينا وعلينا العمل معا للتقليل من
تداعياتها
والسلطات الروسيه اغلقت المنطقه ولا تسمح
لغير حاملي هويتها بالعبور
رافقنا المتطوع ايليا الى اخر حاجز امني
قبل مدينه شبيكنو
تقدر السلطات ان قرابه عشرين الفا نزحوا
من المنطقه منذ بدايه التصعيد الاخير امام
هذا المركز الاغاثي تصطف يوميا طوابير من
النازحين للحصول على المساعدات تؤكد اداره
انها نجحت في احتواء الازمه
على النازحين كل ما يلزمهم من مساعدات امس
مثلا حصل اكثر من 4000 شخص على معاناه
غذائيه وملابس ومستلزمات اخرى عبئنا كل
الامكانات للعمل ما دامت هناك حاجه لذلك
تعترض الدفاعات الروسيه كل يوم هجمات جويه
في سماء بيلغراد المدينه تعيش هدوءا حذرا
يغيب الاستقرار وتغيب معه اي بوادر على
تغير ميداني وشيك
يسهم في الدفع بخط الجبهه بعيدا عن حدود
المقاطعه كما يامل سكانها حيثما
ذهبت في شوارع مدينه بيلجروت تقابلك هذه
العباره ملجا تقول السلطات المقاطعه ان
الوضع صعب لكنه تحت السيطره الحياه هنا
تتكيف مع واقع جديد في هذه الحرب واقع
مختلف ومفتوح على كثير من الاحتمالات
[موسيقى]
قال كبير امناء مجلس الوزراء الياباني ان
سفينتين صينيتين دخلتا مياه اليابان
الاقليميه وحاولتها الاقتراب من قارب صيد
ياباني اضاف ماتسونو ان طوكيو قدمت للصين
مذكره احتجاج بعد دخول سفن تابعه للبحريه
الصينيه المياه الاقليميه لليابان قرب
جزيره ياكوشيما وفي بيجين حتى المتحدث
باسم الخارجيه الصينيه الولايات المتحده
واليابان على الالتزام بمبدا الصين
الواحده والامتناع عن اثاره التوتر في
مضيق تايوان وفي واشنطن قال الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن لدى لقائه رئيس الحكومه
البريطانيه
سيجعل المحيط الهندي اكثر امنا
خصومه تكبر ولكن الحوار باقن بين بيجين
وواشنطن علاقات متوتره اكثر واتصالات
دبلوماسيه سريه وعلنيه واخرى على مستوى
وزراء الخارجيه مبرمجه خلال الاسابيع
المقبله كل طرف غاضب من الاخر بسبب ملفات
ثقيله ومتشابكه حرب المصالح والنفوذ
بينهما لا تسمح بالتقارب ولا بالطلاق
البائن تسر الولايات المتحده على ان الصين
حاليا هي اكبر تهديد استراتيجي تواجهه
وصفات استراتيجيهنا للدفاع الوطني الصيني
بانها التهديد الاساسي لنا فالصين تواصل
اتخاذ اجراءات عدوانيه لاعاده تشكيل منطقه
المحيطين والنظام العالمي لصالحها وتريد
ان تكون القوه الاقليميه المهيمنه في اسيا
خلال سنوات العشر المقبله
وكما جرت العاده قبل واثناء وبعد كل
مناوره عسكريه في المنطقه تندلع حرب
البيانات والتصريحات الغاضبه بين الصين من
جهه والولايات المتحده وحلفائها من جهه
اخرى عندما تكون التدريبات الصينيه
الروسيه في هذا التوقيت بالذات فجرعه
الاستياء تكون اكبر حتى وان انتهت
المناوره الجويه المشتركه بين البلدين فوق
بحر اليابان وبحر شرق الصين يوم الثلاثاء
الماضي فما بعدها من شجب وادانا في
استمرار مره اخرى دافعت بنجين عنها بالقول
انها جزء من خطه التعاون السنويه للجيشين
يا شيخ الدوريه الجويه الاستراتيجيه
المشتركه الاخيره بين الصين وموسكو تتوافق
مع القانون والممارسات الدوليه ولا تستهدف
اي دوله بعينها
دول الجوار حليفه واشنطن لا توافق على هذا
الكلام وتشعر دائما بالتهديد الصيني احتجت
اليابان خلال الساعات الاخيره على دخول
سفن تابعه للبحريه الصينيه مياهها
الاقليميه قرب جزيره
ايضا غاضبه من توغل ما لا يقل عن 37 طائره
حربيه صينيه منطقه الدفاع الجوي
التايوانيه خلال الست ساعات يقول محللون
عسكريون عن زياده التوغلات الجويه الصينيه
في تايوان انها جزء من تكتيكات المنطقه
الرماديه الاوسع التي تبقي الجزيره تحت
الضغط ملف تايوان من الخلافات الجوهريه
بين واشنطن وكان بالطبع حاضرا في الاجتماع
الذي عقد في بيجين في الايام الماضيه بين
دبلوماسيى البلدين في وقت لا تشهد فيه
العلاقات الثنائيه اجمل ايامها علق
الجانبان بايجابيه على اجواء اللقاء الذي
دار بين مساعد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي لش
شرق اسيا ومستشاره الرئيس جو بايدن لشؤون
الصين والتايوان مع مسؤولين من الخارجيه
الصينيه تكرار الاستفزازات المتبادله
والمناورات العسكريه المشتركه وبمسميات
مختلفه في بحر جنوب الصين قد لا يفسد
الاستعدادات لزياره وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي بيجين خلال الاسابيع المقبله في
اخر تصريحاته قال انطوني بلينكن ان
الولايات المتحده لتخير احدا بينها وبين
الصين ترى ما هي خيارات بيجين وواشنطن
لتفادي الاصطدام المباشر في حرب مصالح
ونفوز الى حدود جغرافيه
في فقره المتابعه سيكون لنا نقاش بشان
توتر الامريكي الصيني على تقارير عن منشاه
تجسس تتهيا بيجين لانشائها في كوبا مقابل
حصول هافانا على عده مليارات من الدولارات
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان ملايين
الامريكيين يواجهون اثار الدخان الناتج عن
حرائق الغابات في كندا ووصف رئيس الوزراء
الكندي الحرائق بالاسوا على الاطلاق في
تاريخ البلاد وارجعها للتغير المناخي وقد
ادت حرائق والغابات الى ارتفاع مستويات
تلوث الهواء بشكل قياسي في ولايات الشمال
الشرقي والغرب الاوسط الامريكي وسجلت
نيويورك معدلات تلوث خطيره دفعت السلطات
الى تحذير السكان
يعز الهواء نظيف والرؤيه الجيده في
نيويورك حتى
اشهر ناطحات السحاب في العالم تكاد لا ترى
وقد اخفاها الدخان كما عاد ارتداء الكمامه
حلا مؤقتا لتحسين امكانيات الحصول على
هواء اقل خطوره وضررا في نيويورك وصلت
درجه تلوث الهواء بالجسيمات الدقيقه الى
نسب مرتفعه بلقياسيه فقط اكثر من 300
ميكرو جرام في المتر المكعب خصوصا وانا
منظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر المتوسط السنوي
المقبوله بخمسه ميكرو جرامات في المتر
المكعب ما يحدث في نيويورك الان سببه ليس
في نيويورك نفسها بل في كندا انها حرائق
الغابات التي عبر دخانها الحدود
تشبه تقارير دوريه مافينيويورك بيوم عادي
في مدن اسيويه في الهند وماليزيا والصين
وتايلاند يكاد التلوث المرتفع فيها يكون
سمه بارزه لا تفارقها مع اختلاف سبب
التلوث في هذه المدن الناجمه عن الازدحام
والاعتماد على مصادر الطاقه الاحفوريه
وحرق المحاصيل وغيرها خلف ضباب نيويورك
الخانق والمؤقت يعود الى الواجهه تحد كبير
امام سكان الكوكب التغير المناخي فظهرت
حرائق الغابات التي باتت تتكرر كل عام وفي
كل القارات يعود اتساع نسقها الى مشكله
التلوث ومقاييس التلوث المرتفعه تزيد من
احتمال ارتفاع درجه حراره الارض علاوه على
الوضع الحالي يتوقع العلماء وارتفاع
قياسيا في درجه حراره الارض العام القادم
يجعل منه اكثر الاعوام سخونه مع تنبؤهم
بتشكل ظاهره نيو نهايه العام الحالي
والنينيو تعرف بانها ظاهره طبيعيه تصنف من
ضمن اقوى تقلب مناخي على الارض حيث تكون
المياه الدافئه على سطح المحيط الهادئ
قباله سو احل امريكا الجنوبيه وتنتشر عبر
المحيط دافعه كميات كبيره من الحراره الى
الغلاف الجوي ما يتسبب في عواصف او
فيضانات وحرائق وغيرها يذكر التاريخ ان
العام سبعه وتسعين شاهد ظاهره قويه كلفت
العالم خسائر فاقت 23 الف وفاه واكثر من
خمسه تريليونات دولار
[موسيقى]
عوده الى العلاقات الامريكيه الصينيه حيث
قلل منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي من اهميه
ما جاء في التقرير نشرته
بشان توصل الصين الى صفقه مع كوبا لبناء
قاعده تجسس سريه على بعد 100 ميلا من
ولايه فلوريدا وقال كوربي ان التقرير ليس
دقيقا
صحيفه
نقلت عن مصادر استخباريه امريكيه ان منشاه
التنصت الصينيه المزمعي انشاؤها على
الاراضي الكوبيه ستكون على بعد نحو 160
كيلومترا من ولايه فلوريدا وذلك يعني ان
الموقع سيسمح لاجهزه المخابرات الصينيه
بالاطلاع على الاتصالات الالكترونيه في
جميع انحاء جنوب شرق الولايات المتحده حيث
توجد عده قواعد عسكريه اضافه الى مراقبه
حركه السفن الامريكيه وتعتقد الجهات
الاستخباريه والامنيه الامريكيه ان
القاعده الصينيه ذات قدرات عسكريه
واستخباراتيه متقدمه ويشكل وجودها في
الفناء الخلفي للولايات المتحده تهديدا
جيوسياسيا جديدا غير مسبوق وبسبب نظامها
السياسي وقربها من البر الرئيسي للولايات
المتحده شكلت كوبا تحديا الامريكيين منذ
الستينات عندما شنت واشنطن بالتعاون مع
مرتزقه كوبيينه عمليه عسكريه فاشله لغزو
خليج الخنازير واسقاط الرئيس في ذلك
كاسترو وما لبث الهجوم ان وضع العالم على
شفا حرب نوويه بعد ان اكتشف الطائرات تجسس
امريكيه منصات لصواريخ السوفيتيه منصوبه
على الارض الكوبيه قباله سواحل الولايات
المتحده فيما عرف بازمه خليج الخنازير
التي استمرت ثلاثه عشر يوما التجسس كان
دائما موضوع سجال واتهام متبادل بين
واشنطن وبيجين ومن ابرز الحوادث اسقاط
الجيش الامريكي في شباط فبراير الماضي من
طادا صينيا اخترق المجال الجوي للبلاد
واعلنت واشنطن انه لاغراض التجسس العسكري
بينما قالت الصين ان المنطاد مدني ودخل
الاجواء الامريكيه بسبب ظروف خارجه عن
السيطره
بعد ذلك بنحو اسبوع اتهمت الصين الولايات
المتحده بارسال اكثر من عشره مناطيد الى
مجالها الجوي دون اذن منذ 2022 وهو ماء
نفته واشنطن منتصف مايو الماضي اصدرت
محكمه صينيه حكما بالسجن مدى الحياه على
صيني يحمل الجنسيه الامريكيه لادانته
بالتجسس لصالح واشنطن وقبل ذلك في عام
2022 كشفت وزاره العدل الامريكيه عم وصفته
بعمليه تجسس كبرى حاولت الحكومه الصينيه
تنفيذها لتهريب اشخاص ومعدات من مؤسسات
امريكيه وصيف عام 2021 اتهمت الولايات
المتحده وحلف شمال الاطلسي الصين بشن حمله
تجسس الكتروني عالميه حول هذا الموضوع
ينضم الينا من واشنطن الدكتور ماثيو
كرونيك المستشار السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ومؤ
[موسيقى]
كان هناك محاوله للتاكد من صحه هذه
الاخبار
الصين تعمل على حد على توسيع وجودها خارج
حدودها
وذلك من خلال محطاته التنصت في الارجنتين
والان هناك مشروع محطه في كوبا اعتقد ان
هذا يظهر ان الصين تقول انها غير راغبه في
في تعزيز قوتها العالميه
ثانيا
هذا مثير للقلق بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده
لان كوبا قريبه جدا من الولايات المتحده
وسوف تراقب ذلك عن كثب طيب الان وانت
تتحدث الينا
نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل كوبا تقول ان
تقارير عن استضافتها لقاعده تجسس صينيه
تستهدف الولايات المتحده لا اساس له من
الصحه واريد تعليق فيكتور جاو على كل ذلك
يعني نشر هذه المعلومات في الصحافه
الامريكيه ومن ثم نفيها من قبل المسؤول
الامريكيربي ومن قبل كوبا
شكرا الاستضافه اولا انا لشكوك حول دقه
هذه التقارير الصحفيه في الولايات المتحده
حول هذا الحدث
اسمحوا لي ايضا ان اؤكد ان الصين وكوبا
هما دولتان ذات سياده ولهما علاقات جيده
فيما بينهما
وقد كان هناك زرت كوبا في التسعينات
والصين دعمت كوبا من اجل استقلالها
وطريقتها في تسير الامور وليس هناك اي بلد
اخر له اي تبرير لو ان الصين وكوبا اراد
ان يطور علاقتهما بالطريقه التي يريانها
كوبا هي التي تقرر كيف تريد ان تسير
علاقات الثنائيه
وعلاقه المتحده بذلك قد
تغضب او تستاء ما المشكله لتستاء
الناس لا يمكن ان يفرضوا امرهم على العالم
ولا على كيف يمكن لبلدين مثل الصين وكوبا
ان يطور علاقتهم الثنائيه ولكن هذا لا
يستهدف تطوير العلاقات العاديه سيد جاو
التقرير يتحدث عن
ان الصين مزمعه على انشاء يعني محطه
استخباريه تستهدف الولايات المتحده في
كوبا
يه ينبغي ان نتاكد من دقه
التقارير التي اشك فيها كثيرا ثانيا لو ان
الصين او كوبا او اي بلد اخر ارادوا ان
يديروا على اقتيم الثنائيه على ارضها طبقا
لقانونهم فهذا لا علاقه له بالولايات
المتحده هل تريدون ان اؤكد على هذه النقطه
هذا
يدخل في اطار سياده البلدين
دكتور مافيو كرونك هل ما نشر يندرج في
اطار التطوير الطبيعي للعلاقات الثنائيه
اعتقد ان ذلك الهدف هو هدف الولايات
المتحده لو كانت هذه التقارير صحيحه
وكانت هذا المركز للتجسس على الولايات
المتحده انا اتفق مع السيد جاو على انه
على من حق كوبا والصين ان يطور علاقاتهم
الثنائيه
بطريقه ريانها وامن ان سيدغاو
والصين انه من حق
الولايات المتحده في اسيا ان يطوروا
علاقتهم مع بلدان المنطقه شكرا لك دكتور
ماثي اوكرانيا
ومؤلف كتاب عوده التنافس بين القوى العظمى
من واشنطن وشكرا لك فيكتور جاو نائب رئيس
مركز الصين والعولمه من بيج
ونختم جولتنا بالحوار الذي كنت قد اجريته
مع وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
ومقاربتها للملفات الاقليميه وسالتها في
البدايه عن اولويات الحرب ضد تنظيم الدوله
في هذه المرحله
كان هناك اجتماع هامه
للتحالف العالميه ضد تنظيم داعش تنظيم
داعش لا يزال يشكل تهديدا للكثير من الدول
لقد تراجع التنظيم وهزم على الارض ولكنه
لا يزال يمارس بعد انشطته عن طريق فروع له
او هجومات هنا وهناك وبالتالي لا يجب ان
نعتبر ان الحرب على داعش قد انتهت يجب ان
نستمر يجب ان تبقى جهودنا متضافره اليوم
كان هناك 86 دوله ومنظمه دوليه للمواصله
العمل الذي بدانا به وان المناطق التي
تحررت من داعش استعاده حياه طبيعيه ولكن
يتعين علينا الا ننسى هذا القتال الذي
اخذناه مع شركائنا واصدقائنا والان نفكروا
بالتنميه واعاده البناء والرخاء والا سوف
تبقى الارضيه التي انتشر عليها فكر تنظيم
داعش وبالتالي تتضافر لنكرر هذه الرساله
لتقديم عدد من المساهمات فرنسا اعلنت عن
مساهمتها ولننظر ايضا خارج منطقه المشرق
التهديدات بسبب كل من يقلد داعش او فروع
داعش في مناطق اخرى في القاره الافريقيه
لسوء الحظ وايضا في اسيا الوسطى وخاصه في
افغانستان بالتالي هذا تهديد عالمي ونحن
مصممون على مواجهته معا وبشكل متحد من
الدول التي عانت من هذا الامر في المنطقه
العراق وسوريا تحديدا واليوم هناك خطوات
تتخذ من جانب بعض الدول العربيه باتجاه
التطبيع مع النظام السوري او مبادره ما
تعرف خطوه مقابل خطوه كيف ما هو موقفكم
انتم في فرنسا من هذا الامر
لو كانت خطوه مقابل خطوه
او خطوه خطوه
كان يمكن لنا ان نفهم المنطق
في هذه القضيه السوريه
خضعت او تعرضت لعقوبات من مجلس الامن
وقاده عدد من الهجومات في السنوات الماضيه
لو كان ذلك خطوه خطوه او خطوه مقابل خطوه
تحترم سوريا التزاماتها وتسمح بعوده
السكان الذين
تركوا السوريه بامن واذا ما عادت الى
عنايه الصحيه والعمل
والاسكان ولا تقوم بالتجاره المخدرات ولا
تقوم بانشطه تسعصع استقرار المنطقه وتكافح
الارهاب حينئذ نعم هناك ضرب يمكن ان تسلكه
سوريا لتعود وتندمج في المجتمع الدولي
وهذا كان يكون خبرا جيدا ولكن لسوء الحظ
ليس هذا ما نراه
الجامعه العربيه اتخذت هذا القرار بكل
سياده لاعاده النظام السوري اعاده السوريه
الى
الجامعه العربيه من المفاجئ انها فعلت ذلك
بدون مقابل وبدون ان تكون هذه الخطوات قد
تمت وبدون ان تكون سوريا سارت على هذا
الدرب وبالتالي
نحن حائرين
ولا نؤيد هذه الفكره القائله بتطبيع مع
السوريه بدون التزامات والتزامات تنفذ في
الميدان لكن من قاموا بهذه المبادره
السيده الوزيره يقولون ان المسار الذي
اتبع من جانب المجتمع الدولي لحل هذه
الازمه والازمات التي تفرعت منها لم ينجح
اذا ما البدائل
على احترام قرارات مجلس الامن السيده
الوزيره رحبتم مؤخرا بالتقارب الحاصل بين
السعوديه وايران في المنطقه
ماذا تتوقعون ان ينتج عن هذا التقارب ماذا
تريدون ان ينتج
معك حق لقد حيينا هذا التقارب واكرر هذا
الشيء جيد فنحن بشكل عام نؤمن
بفضائل الحوار هذا الاتفاق ترجم عمليا عن
طريق اعاده فتح السفارات وهو لا شك انه
سوف يساهم في تخفيف حده التوتر وربما سوف
يحمل استقرار اضافي للمنطقه والمنطقه به
امس الحاجه لذلك نحن جميعا نعرف التهديدات
ونرى تصرفات ايران والخطر الذي تشكل هذه
التصرفات على الدول المجاوره هناك ايضا
الملف النووي ايران بعيده جدا عن احترام
التزاماتها الدوليه تجاه الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
واذا كان هذا الاتفاق الذي تم توقيع عليه
بين السعوديه وايران هو مساهمه نحو احترام
افضل
للقانون وقواعد الحياه في المجتمع الدولي
هذا سوف يكون جيدا وفي كل الاحوال حي هذا
اتفاق وكررت هذه التحيه صباح اليوم ذكرت
اليوم في المؤتمر الصحفي مع رئيس الوزراء
القطري في زياره ايكون الى الدوحه ان
فرنسا تعمل مع قطر للتشجيع على ايجاد حلول
للعقبات السياسيه في لبنان هل لنا ان نفهم
ما هي هذه المبادره التي يجري العمل عليها
اعتقد ان كل اصدقاء لبنان وتعرفون كم ان
لبنان متميز بالنسبه لفرنسا وعزيز على قلب
فرنسا وعزيز على قلوب كل الفرنسيين وليس
فقط
الحكام نريد جميعا ان نرى لبنان في وضع
اخر نحن نعرف ان الوضع مجمد
وهذا الطريق المسدود او اللبنانيون في
طريق المسود منذ فتره طويله جدا ونحن
نواجه نداء للقاده اللبنانيين على التحلي
بحس المسؤوليه وتبني القرارات الضروريه
للبنان
لتشغيل المؤسسات ان يكون هناك رئيس يمثل
كل البلاد ان تكون هناك حكومه كامله
الصلاحيات القيام بالاصلاحات المطلوبه
التوقيع على اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي
هذه الاصلاحات التي بدونها سوف يستمر
الوضع الاقتصادي صعب جدا اللبنانيون
يعانون نريد ان نكون الى جانب لبنان
نساعده ثقافيا انسانيا واشكال اخرى من
التعاون نحن حقا الى جانب لبنان وساكن
سياسيا نريد مساعدته على الخروج من هذا
الطريق المسدود وان يعود لبنان الذي نحبه
الرئيس الفرنسي اعلن بالامس عن تعيين
مبعوث خاص الى لبنان هو السيد جائز رودريا
ما هي الخطوات المقبله التي يفترض ان يقوم
بها السيد لودريان في هذا المجال راسه
هذه فكره جيده جدا ان نعزز عملنا الى جانب
اللبنانيين بينما هناك بعض الاستحقاقات
التي تقترب الصيف على
ولايه حاكم البنك المركزي ستنتهي قريبا
هناك انتخابات نيابيه يجب ان تجري نريد ان
نكون الى جانب اللبنانيين يوميا
للقاء كل الاطراف في المعنيه ونقال نقول
لهم ونكرر لهم انه عليهم ان يتفقوا
ان اللبنانيين يمكن ان يتفقوا في الماضي
ويمكنهم ان يتفقوا في المستقبل مع الاخذ
في كل الحساسيات السياسيه قد وجدت مثلا
اتفاق او توصلت الى قرار مشترك لترسيم
الحدود المحبه البحريه وهذا كان شيء جيد
جدا يمكن ان يتحقق ذلك مجددا نحن نريد ان
نكون قوه للدعم لكي يستعيد اللبنانيون
زمام الامور هذا اذا السيد لودريان سوف
يزور لبنان على الارجح قريبا اعتقده امل
ان يذهب في خلال شهر يونيو حزيران ونامل
من الان وحتى الصيف ان يكون لبنان خطا
لنفسه دربا جديدا بمساعده اصدقائه او
لوحده لان لبناني لان اللبنانيين الى ذلك
بعجاله السيده الوزيره انطلق اليوم
المرحله الثانيه من الحوار الاستراتيجي مع
الدوحه ما هي ابرز عناوينه نعم الهدف
الثاني لزياره في المنطقه
كانت ان اتي الى قطر بصفه وزيره اوروبا
وشؤون الخارجيه كنت زرت قطر منذ فتره
طويله جدا ولكن في مهام او في وظيفه اخرى
الحوار الاستراتيجي الاول انعقد منذ سنه
وكان علينا ان نعقد
الدوره الثانيه للحوار واستغليت فرصه فرصه
زيارتي لهذه المنطقه لنعقد هذا الحوار
الاستراتيجي وكان هناك مجموعات عمل اجتمعت
سابقا وحضرت له بايجاز وباختصار بكلمه
علاقتنا قديمه جدا
وثيقه جدا في المجال الاقتصاديه الامنيه
الدفاع الثقافه الاستثمارات التعليم
العالي وهناك امثله كثيره ولكننا نريد
هذا نزولا عند رغبه سحب السمو الامير
ورئيس جمهوريه الفرنسيه ان نعطي بعدا
جديدا لهذا
التعاون
الطاقه التحولات الرقميه التحديات
العالميه الى اخره هناك اشياء كثيره علينا
ان نفعلها وسوف اقول ذلك هنا ولم اقل ذلك
في المؤتمر الصحفي رئيس الجمهوريه سوف
يكون سعيدا جدا بزياره قطر او باستقبال
صاحب السمو امير قطر في باريس لكي نرتقي
بهذه العلاقه الى مستوى اعلى اكثر
نهايه حصادي هذه الليله نشكر لكم متابعتكم
الان الى جولتنا منتصف الليل مع حسن جمول
وسيلاول
[موسيقى]